[Music]  best gift I've ever received my family  johnny depp and vanessa paradis his son  is reportedly not doing well the 45 year  old French actress reportedly missed the  Paris premiere of her latest film knife  and heart to be with her 16 year old son  Jack according to the French outlet  public the movie's director Yan Gonzalez  shared the news with press at the event  saying quote unfortunately vanessa  paradis was not able to join us tonight  she had to be absent because of her  son's serious health problems Depp and  Paradis dated from 1998 to 2012 and  share two children together  19 year-old daughter lily-rose and jack  despite the fame the actor has told the  et he's an everyday parent dad you know  my kiddies were around a lot for the  shoot and came on set quite a bit